[Music]
[ __ ] up you got most of it oh [ __ ]
yeah that was a lot i felt saliva on the
left
okay thank god just swallow it
hey do this do a really tiny piece all
right here we go
so
make it smaller
who andrew tate is yeah i know i'm about
them a little bit i've heard the name of
the alpha male brother
speak on it everybody speak on it before
i say something everyone asked us to do
like a um andrew tate uh what do you
call it react like they wanted us to
watch it but i've been seeing this guy
pop up like
so much yeah and i also thought that he
was a joke so i thought that he was
playing a character
but people were getting angry at him and
i was like oh that's so funny you guys
are mad at a comedic character like
alice jones kind of [ __ ] yeah but i
didn't know that he was
he had he that was real he's a pro he's
a pro fighter dude he's actually a
pretty good kickboxer that's how i like
i watch his i've seen his fights it's
pretty good but i thought his character
like the way that he was acting i
thought that was a joke the
self-described misogynist yeah yeah from
what i've seen i feel like he says [ __ ]
just to get social media mad that's how
i've like what are some of his like
famous i guess i thought uh like one of
his hottest takes is that uh women who
are raped should bear part of the
responsibility
that's probably one of the most famous
like things that people are pissed at
oh
women women should be property like of
the man i saw that
which is like okay you're calling the
bible now
exploring how i feel because the clips
that i've seen um i've never really
understood why he was so controversial
and one of the ones i saw it was like i
think he was saying how he lives in
romania or something yeah and the reason
why is he goes like
in america it's
like there's corruption literally
everywhere right but he's like but in
america the corruption is reserved for
the elite so if you know the right
people or if you have enough money then
you can uh like those guys are
untouchable right he goes i don't want
to live in a place
where i know corruption exists
but
i can't partake versus in a romania if
someone pulls me over or cop pulls me
over i just give them here's a hundred
bucks
let me go they're like so like the
corruption is accessible to everyone and
i'm like that kind of makes sense
apparently they said that possible
corruption like he moved there also
because the sex trafficking laws and
laws to protect women are so weak so
that he can do a lot of
like sex trafficking shady [ __ ] he just
yeah that's what he's known for right
and that's it he said himself that he
moved there because he's less likely to
be charged for sexual assault oh god
what the [ __ ] so that's crazy crazy this
dude has uh officially been banned from
tick-tock youtube instagram and facebook
dude there was a point in time where he
was just popping up randomly and
everything that's the thing i feel like
so people are talking about them so much
now because people a lot of people are
reposting his [ __ ] crazy takes he was
everywhere yeah like so he's like just
tick tocks of him just saying wild [ __ ]
are going crazy you know what i'm saying
yeah and i think it all just leads to
people i think that's why he does it on
purpose because it all leads up to his
like website or whatever he's trying to
push is he say so he's saying like
cancelable things
but then it's actually doing the
opposite and it's making them viral yeah
yeah wow and
he's saying
as he responds to all of his accounts
getting banned and stuff like that he's
still uh
he's saying there's a running
contradiction in today's society where
men are encouraged to speak and be open
slash honest with how they feel but are
generally met with a negative response
to their truth that's uh that's what a
spokesperson for him said recently about
him being banned from all social
platforms well if you say you should be
beating chicks
that's not gonna be vulnerable
[Laughter]
you told me
all i said was i just want to rape some
girls man why the [ __ ] no that's crazy
spokesperson says banning andrew t from
these platforms might seem the answer
but it isn't that simple removing tate's
voice doesn't allow for a kinder
hate-free society so this former
kickboxer found internet infamy on
social media for his audacious views on
women to catch everybody up a 35 year
old who brands himself as a quote
success coach has publicly claimed that
women can't drive that 18 year old women
are more attractive than 25 year olds
because they've been through less dick
and that woman should shut the [ __ ] up
have kids sit at home be quiet and make
coffee
his videos and inflammatory comments
have been labeled as sexist and
misogynistic that's why it seems like a
character
on youtube becoming the latest social
platforms yeah
i first saw i first saw him on your
mom's house on tom segura's podcast and
they would always they would have this
segment called cool guys of the week and
they would like shred on the guitar or
whatever and they would they would take
these videos of like these wild crazy
dudes that would say either really
cringey stuff or like videos of them
trying to get girls or something like
that right so they would like pick up
artists yeah yeah so they highlighted
him and i was like dude this guy is
obviously and at the time this is like
two years ago this is when i first heard
about it whoa it's been around for a
while yeah but it was like very surface
level it was like i heard about him this
is [ __ ] he says [ __ ] like that
like and he goes you should make me two
coffees you know bring me two copies
instead of one so i don't have to ask
for a second
and then they brought him on the podcast
and they were like it was like a
character and it would seem like all fun
and games he was playing along with uh
tom segura's wife christina positsky and
i was like oh this is [ __ ] funny but
then now i see him pop up like two years
later and he just said this wild crazy
[ __ ] i don't even know he was saying
about six i didn't do um i've only seen
the clips right but hannah's done a deep
dive on him because she thought that the
character was super [ __ ] interesting
and then i was like
what it's just a joke like if this guy's
can't be serious she goes no actually
so what he does is he masks how he
really feels through animation and
joking but he's because i think what he
said uh was
no these are actually my thoughts but i
do it in a funny way because i'm just
like i like being funny about it but i
do believe these things right i think so
i was like oh where are you dude i can't
i can't and i think the issue right that
people are having is that like
a lot of
impressionable like younger dudes are
are not realizing
like you know we look at this [ __ ] we're
like this is [ __ ] ridiculous this is
a character i think a lot of like
younger
younger dudes who are like yeah man
these [ __ ] [ __ ] are playing into
it they don't realize that this
[ __ ] is like
you know maybe they're mad because they
ain't got no girls growing up or
something like that and they're like
he's right bro i need to move to romania
[Laughter]
too coffee but it's like the alex jones
argument right there's some things that
he talks about where it's like oh [ __ ]
he's kind of right but then he says
there's one thing which is the sandy
hook stuff that discredits all of it and
it's to the point where his community is
like yeah sandy hook was [ __ ] fake
right right like that's the damage that
this [ __ ] is doing well there's
so many different things that are [ __ ]
up but like one of the things is that um
the social media platforms have now
de-platformed him are like yeah we're
not gonna stand for like misogynistic
views being perpetuated whatever they
let him get to this point yeah so they
only canceled them once because
everybody else was like no so it's not
as a question of standards on the thing
we're talking like uh
it says right here before he was done
from the platform uh tate was one of the
most watched users with videos amassing
13.8 billion views he was he was the
most searched person more than the i
think all the kardashians combined
really he was wow wow
i'm telling you man like on my youtube
thing like my youtube algorithm is very
[ __ ] it's like fighting comedy things
podcast whatever and then all of a
sudden this [ __ ] pops up i was
like i'd never watch any of this [ __ ]
because he's in line with like macho
[ __ ] so i thought you were you think i
like macho stuff dude i thought you were
mistakenly i watched
bacon videos i never took them as macho
[ __ ] i took them as in cell [ __ ]
well it's that's a thing that's that's
weird it's like he's they've had lots of
like debate things where it's like him
on one side and then like an actual
incel person and he just shreds them to
bits and i think that's what people like
is like he's kind of the people's hero
against like soy boy mentality oh you
know as like weird as that sounds like
yeah yeah i get it that's why they look
at that like but that's not because for
him he's like he's a very like
take your life into your own hands and
make it where you want it to be type of
death and he like kind of shrouds it as
like this is life empowering advice like
i saw a whole thread where he was like
if you if you've ever watched star wars
you will never accomplish anything in
life
he's like i have sex with attractive
women because i've never seen star wars
that's hilarious i've never watched star
wars that's funny so it's like really
funny triggers a whole community
community of people we're like what the
[ __ ] i watch star wars i get [ __ ] and
also you know what i'm saying but also
the people who are like
star wars he's right i would be a
millionaire
i've never watched anymore
this was a whole twitter thread where
it's like obviously he's baiting people
right he knows he obviously knows what
works like if he's gonna look at his own
numbers and see what he said for these
high you know high number shots and of
course he's gonna repeat it he has also
outwardly claimed that he was simply
quote playing a comedic character he's
like actually now he's gonna say that
yeah now controversy it's like alex
jones did have you guys seen the video
that came out of him like whipping a
girl yeah he likes in the bed he's like
smacking her yeah i was like oh [ __ ] is
this real or like is it a skin care
big brother
he was he was on big brother yeah [ __ ]
as a real a celebrity or a regular
person i don't know it was it was way
back for the uk one i think damn oh that
doesn't count i don't like what he said
about asian hate i'll tell you that what
do you say about that he said he's all
what is those asian hate [ __ ] people get
their ass whipped every day why are we
putting a color on it oh [ __ ] i was like
that's what you think it is really
that's not uh
[Laughter]
leave it to bart guys
but his timing is weird
he said that five years ago he's playing
the algorithm because it's hot in the
streets if he said that five years ago
somebody else would get mad he doesn't
he doesn't believe it's real
so i was like okay
meanwhile we marched every day to stop
asia [ __ ] we got floor wheel drive
coverage
they just blasted a [ __ ] asian lady
just didn't do it
right now yeah
yeah they just walked up and just
[ __ ] shot her up and now because of
this video
he's going to show up in in jk news
algorithm because of y'all
we've already done this if it wasn't for
you but he's banned off of what
instagram youtube all that
but not his content just just him
personally yeah but didn't they take
down his content or people are reposting
it's going you can't you can't even take
it down faster than people could put it
up you know this reminds me of alex
jones where you know the character he
became the character
like you play you you [ __ ] method
your character so hard that you become
that
all it takes is a case to be like it was
just a character guy sorry yeah it's a
cop out these days but that's i think
it's a bigger problem not only what he's
saying like okay fine he's saying crazy
[ __ ] inciting whatever personalities to
be amplified the main thing is that he
has a multi-level marketing paywall
thing that you subscribe to so i think
because he's making money off of this
that's why the platforms don't like it i
don't think it's just what he's saying
yeah platforms don't give a [ __ ] what
people say until they're like taking
revenue yeah and he's making this thing
we've got to sign up for this mentorship
kind of thing it's pretty good you sign
other people up at hustle university
yeah i think the [ __ ] university the
fact that it's an mlm is what platforms
are like oh we can't host this guy
because he's you can't gain the system
he was supposed to fight the paul
brothers too was it yeah i think jake
parker was like talking about i mean he
is a he's a good fighter right i want to
see that he probably wouldn't be in
boxing or are they gonna do kickboxing
now they're going to do kickboxing with
him a bunch of ladies now
damn that's nice because they [ __ ] up
all these girls now dude everyone who's
pissed out of
royal rumble oh my god i feel like why
do i feel like the women would start
attacking each other but but here's the
thing though if the paul brothers want
to be like well if jake paul wants to be
a little more mike likable he would
fight a guy like andrew tate yeah that's
true yeah that's a good story if we're
like
conflict of fans they kind of would have
the same
pool maybe splitting the vote i know the
ideology is jake's like i agree
he's like you're kind of reasonable
don't put that on jay paul
pass him well after eating hot cheetos
and seaweed
[Music]
[Music]
my